hi glamour it's jen atkin founder of way
hair care and mainaducts.com
and i'm here to tell you about my beauty
routine
so the hairstyle that makes me feel like
i have all the sass
is clean hair so when it's dirty i use a
super dry shampoo
and fake it until i make it
best beauty hack that i've picked up not
from a celebrity but from celebrity
makeup artist would be mary phillips who
told me
that past a certain age i needed to
retire my glittery eyeshadow
i take my makeup from zero to extra
by i think adding a little bit of a
liner
maybe a bright colored lip my most used
hair hack of all time would be
day three when you don't want to wash
and your hair is super dirty and you
just throw it in a bun
my biggest piece of advice to kick ass
as your true self
is to learn the importance of unplugging
don't just be on your phone
all day every day and then i would say
you're never too old to start something
new and take a new path
my biggest beauty fills would have to be
over plucking my brows in high school
and then cutting bangs when i was
hormonal all right i usually don't
answer this question but my favorite
ever
celeb hair look would have to be this
braided like
crown halo braid i did on khloe
kardashian back in like 2012.
she won't let me live it down she hated
it from the second i did it
once a year she sends me a picture of
her in this miserable braid and it's my
favorite thing because it just makes me
laugh
let's get into this i'm going to show
you my kick-ass beauty routine
start with my let's elfing do it
palette comes in two shades that was
light medium
and then this is the medium deep i'm
gonna start off with my eye shadow
i'm gonna take the lightest color here
and just go over the top of my lid
and it's going to kind of be like my
base this is really nice doing this
not in my car which is where i normally
do my makeup i'm going to mix this
bronzer here with the eyeshadow color
and just kind of go into the crease and
start on the outer edge
next step i'm going to take the medium
shade eyeshadow and i'm going to now
kind of go in that outer crease and
really kind of go all the way in and
just kind of go into the crease here
to create a little bit of a dimension
and then i'm going to take that first
brush
and that light color and kind of mix a
little bit of that bronzer with the
light color
and just lightly go over the top section
here
just to kind of really blend that shadow
that i just used
and then i'm going to take the darkest
eyeshadow shade and this is actually a
trick that i learned
from my makeup artist friend mary
phillips and instead of using
liner during the day i actually like to
use shadow as my liner just kind of
gives a nice softer look
so now i'm gonna take that bronzer color
and i'm just gonna lightly go
on the very bottom of my eye right here
to kind of blend it all together
the next step i'm gonna take that sheer
matte blush color
and i am going to add a little bit
here in the cheeks i actually like to
take my finger
and just put a tiny bit of that blush on
the top section
of the shadow that we just did again to
kind of like
bring everything together really nicely
something i learned along the way in all
my years of working with celeb makeup
artist is to take
a little bit of highlighter and you
actually want to go in like a c
shape along your eyebrows and then i am
going to take
my finger again and i'm just going to
use a little bit of the highlighter here
at
the bottom of my brow bone
guys i made my dream product it's a
clear brow
pomade that you can use to tame your
brow hairs
or tame your baby hairs and flyaways
it's long
lasting and it dries clear and yes
you can use it on your mustache as well
i don't have one anymore all right
next up we've got my perfect two in one
lipstick and lip liner duo there's
ready to go bring it on brown
and my personal favorite self-made pink
and it has lip liner on one side and
then lipstick on the other
and it's a two in one because you know
i'm all about
convenience so you can just throw it in
your purse and
reapply it all day last but not least
we have face mist it has an irresistible
coconut
scent
just like i'm in tulum okay there you
have it this is my kick-ass makeup
routine
in no time
all right guys so here are some of my
favorite must-have products that i
cannot live without first up
is all these sleep gummies they honestly
put you to sleep without making you feel
like you're hungover the next day
next up is duh my dyson
coral because i don't have to have a
cord i can do hair on set
out in the wilderness i actually did
hair
for my next favorite thing kim and
kendall kkw fragrance collab this is the
amber scent
and i literally like bathe in it this is
my second bottle i've already gone
through
olive is also a really good scent bad
habit
emma chamberlain can do no wrong i'm
obsessed with her coffee and i just love
trying any oils and i think it's a
really
really
good one it doesn't make you like feel
too greasy and next up is cloud do
by summer fridays i love everything that
summer fridays does
i think everything that they do is just
they can do no wrong and this is one of
my favorite
favorite favorite moisturizing products
i'm a little partial but whey curl cream
first of all we worked so hard on this
packaging it's a matte package it just
looks so luxe and the curl cream
was tested by over a thousand people in
our community and
i really think it turned out so great
and i love it love it love it step is
the glossier
makeup bag i'm obsessed look at all the
different compartments that it has
i don't even know if it's just for
makeup but i use it for hair stuff i
love love love this bag and then last
but not least maine addicts we have
these amazing bobby pin holders that i
wish
existed like 15 years ago
it's easy to adjust you can put whatever
you need in there
it's like a fishing tool box thanks
glamour for visiting me here at the way
hq and for going through all my beauty
rituals
and my elf collection available now i
hope you guys love it i'll see you next
time